-Welcome back.
It is so great to see you.
Thank you so much
for being on the show.
-I have to acknowledge
Questlove, though.
His -- That documentary,
"Summer Of Soul" was --
-Yep. That was --
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-He nailed it.
Every time you're here,
we always have a good time.
I want to talk to you
about everything.
But, first, I want to talk
to you about --
You're an unbelievable actor.
You're an unbelievable activist.
And then, you changed
the entire game with
"The Jane Fonda Workout."
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
That came out 40 --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was doing --
I was checking it out.
It came out 40 years ago.
Did you have any idea
that it was going to be as big?
-Oh, absolutely.
It was totally strategic.
The timing of it.
[ Laughter ]
Not.
I took a class with a woman --
a talented woman
name Leni Cazden,
and it became a blockbuster,
and I did not expect it,
the whole thing.
You know, I got all these
musicians to give me songs,
because it came out
first as a record.
And, of course, they all agreed
to it, because they didn't --
they didn't think
it was going to be anything.
And they didn't even ask
for a percentage
or anything like that.
-Yeah, they just --
well, I have -- This is the --
This is the workout album.
This is the album right here.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You have Jimmy Buffett on here.
You have REO Speedwagon.
The Jacksons are on here.
This is a great album.
I think you invented
the very first gym playlist.
-For sure. Yeah. Who knew?
-Who knew this is it?
-Yes.
-What is the exercise
playlist you have today?
-Oh, honey, there's no song
slow enough for me
to do a workout to.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-It's all --
I'm almost 85 years old.
You can't move fast.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
Almost 85?
You look so good.
-Yeah, you look pretty
good yourself too, I must say.
-Thank you, pal.
-We were all talking
about it backstage.
-Look, I want to --
[ Laughter ]
You know, you're always
doing something new.
And last time we were here,
we were talking about
the live stream series you did,
"Fire Drill Fridays."
-Yeah, still doing it.
Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
It brings attention
to climate change.
But now you've taken it
a step further.
Okay.
You've launched the Jane Fonda
Climate PAC.
-That's right.
-Can you tell
everyone about this?
-Sure.
Well, you've got to have
the rallies and the --
and we're gonna do
in-person rallies again.
Tune in to "Fire Drill Fridays"
on Fridays,
and I'll tell you all about
what we're going to be doing
leading up
to the midterm elections.
But what I've learned,
what we've all learned,
is that it's not enough.
The fossil-fuel industry has a
stranglehold on our government.
They give money to Democrats
and to Republicans,
and we've got to get
rid of those types
that take money
from the fossil-fuel industry.
And we'll replace them
with climate champions
who really will work
for the people
and not for big corporations.
That's what the Jane Fonda
Climate PAC does.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And -- Yes.
Out.
-I think we all want this.
-Next week I'm going to be
in Michigan for Andy Levin.
I'm going to be working for him,
for Barbara Lee,
for Donna Edwards.
I mean, there's some great
climate champions out there
that we need to support,
because tens of millions
of dollars are in
to trying to defeat them.
And so, if you want to join us
and find out more, thejanepac --
P-A-C --
dot com.
Janepac.com.
-Yeah, Janepac.
That's what I'm talking about
right there.
-That's it.
-I love that you're doing this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We all want --
We all want this.
When you're not busy
saving the planet,
you're also still doing movies.
I just saw this cast right here,
if I can just show
a picture of this.
Some awesome VIPs here.
But one person sticks out
in my head a little bit.
This is Rita Moreno, this is
Lily Tomlin, Tom Brady --
-Sally Field.
[ Light laughter ]
-Tom -- I said Tom Brady.
Yeah.
That's -- I mean,
that's really Tom Brady?
-Oh, he's so cute.
-Yeah, he really is.
[ Laughter ]
-And nice.
-He is so cute and nice.
What is this?
-It's a partly true story
about four women in their 80s --
Well, Rita is 90 and Sally
is 75, but who's counting?
-Who's counting? Yeah.
-Yeah.
Who have a real thing for Tom
Brady for all kinds of reasons.
And we have adventures.
We go to the famous game
in Houston
where they were down --
way, way down --
and they came back.
-Oh, yeah.
-That's the game --
-He's done some amazing things.
-Oh, my God.
-He's kind of a magician,
that guy.
Have you met Tom --
-Yeah.
And I had a scene
with Gronkowski.
See, my character writes
sex novels about football.
So I wrote --
She wrote a book.
She wrote a book --
[ Cheers ]
♪♪
-I like this.
-What? She wrote a book called
"Between a Gronk
and a Hard Place."
[ Laughter ]
I had a funny little scene
with Gronk.
And, oh, man, is he funny.
-He's a great guy too.
-And is he tall.
-He's fun.
He's a blast.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want you to come back, please,
when that film comes out.
But we're here tonight
to talk about --
you play the dragon in "Luck."
-I do.
-This beautiful animated movie.
-She's a great character.
-I mean, that's fun to --
Do you like doing voice-overs?
-I've wanted to break in to
voice-overs in a feature film.
This is my first feature film.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Partly because I love animated
films, partly because I'm old,
and it's a really good gig
for an old person.
You don't have to worry about
how you look and your hair
and all that kind of thing.
You know,
you just go and have fun.
And it was really fun.
-Yeah, show up in your pajamas.
And, yeah, you go --
-Yeah, you can go
in your pajamas.
She's -- You know,
she's very flirtatious.
She's the CEO
of the kingdom of Luck.
-Yeah, I love the story
about it all too.
-It's a wonderful story.
-It is fun.
And they know how to do it
over there over at Apple TV+.
-Yeah, Skydance.
-I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Jane Fonda
as the dragon in "Luck."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Twice in one day.
You were on the Luck floor
this morning, right?
-Yes, that was me.
-I thought so.
Luck levels
looking excellent as usual.
See you next week.
Oh, I'm so happy. There are
so few creatures here
I can actually look in the eye.
We lucky ladies of stature
ought to stick together,
don't you think?
-Yeah, come on.
That's Jane Fonda in "Luck."
I always love having you here.
I'm honored that you come
and do our show.
And we always have fun together.
And I thought tonight --
We like to play games
on this show.
And I thought, would you
like to play a game?
And you said yes.
And then I told you
the type of game,
and you still kind of said yes.
But you haven't said no.
But now we're live on TV,
so you can't really say no.
[ Laughter ]
So when we come back,
we're going to play a game of
"Egg Roulette" with Jane.